you look like a vision always thank you
and i gotta say you look like a vision
in the thick of the jungle too that
purple jumpsuit can we please talk about
it how what would you like to say
because i are you tired of talking about
her yet because she is a star in her own
right he really is the star of this film
you know it's just again i gotta give it
give it to our costume designer like to
find the right material yeah that
wouldn't
uh be
shedding its way through the dr which
the last thing you want to do is destroy
a beautiful jungle with your your vanity
um
it didn't scratch channing's face which
was very important to her um but it had
to do a lot of things it had to be in a
lot of places do a lot of things and it
was just it was epic i mean very much so
you say even that you might be talking
about her for the rest of your life yeah
so she's she's very she's basically
still embedded in parts of my body but
it's okay i'm sure she is and probably
uh changing scalp as well no it didn't
it didn't she sure did she didn't want
to hurt channing he blessed him yeah
how might this be one of the most iconic
wardrobe pieces in all of them i'm like
what i'm looking at you look at you boss
ladies
you know it's like every jungle movie
that i've seen it's you know the
wardrobe is always sort of khakis
neutrals you don't want to stand out so
i love the fact that this was the exact
opposite um it's just a great color
it screams look at me yeah yeah and so
incognito in the jungle i saw a video
channing had posted on the gram of he
picked you up and he drops both of you
into the water tank right before you
wrap filming it just seems like
the set exuded fun and friendship how
would you describe it exactly that it's
like i think we were so desperate for
human contact that we would have had fun
even if we hated each other um but jan
and i are
super compatible as actors as parents as
friends is um
just as good partners we make a good
team we make a really good team it is
evident but who broke character most i
hear it possibly could be a tower i was
i was the worst i was the worst just
because channing is really
very really funny he just and i just
again i was just so happy to have human
contact but channing is really funny i
can't wait to see the physicality of it
all in the comedy that's going to be
between the two of you you also have
bullet train coming out with brad pitt
and it is well i'm like i'm only in
brad's head i i really i'm i'm serious
i'm in brad's head i handle it are you
disappointed about that
we need more we make up for it in this
this is true yeah what do you appreciate
about that friendship the friendship
that you have with brad i honestly don't
know brad that well we just keep doing
each other favors and we don't really
know each other no why i'm not a lie
serious not a lie not a lie we just keep
i think we were probably past life
friends of something you know but but i
just for some reason he asked you know
for help i show up i ask for help he
shows up and
maybe mutual respect club i don't know
mad respect for you sandy if i'm ever
going to get lost in the jungle honey
i'm calling you maybe channing is back
up and of course brad pitt you want
channing to help you but you want me to
address you a min sister maybe since
heels uh i don't know if you know this
this year marks the 35th anniversary of
your film debut and first
film credits
1987 the hangman oh my gosh the hangman
which was shot here in new york city
why don't you come over and see me
sometime
i remember i had to bring my own
wardrobe
i got squibbed and i was shot which was
fantastic
um
super low budget i'm assuming because
you know it was uh
but you know what it was like i got cast
i got a job which is pretty amazing
pretty amazing
sandra we've been watching it ever since
i don't know how my vhs have you been
watching the hangman no you just
injected but i will tell you this my vhs
of speed i don't even know how it was
still in one piece well speed is a solid
film you know hangman
okay finally i love the character
posters and basically they have an
asterisk said uh you are not blank i
feel like they're completely cast that's
not what you are not blank so for your
character it is you are not an
adventurer oh yes
i am
by your name why not oh god the list is
so long oh probably oh seriously um
i am not
oh god i'm not a quitter
not a quitter
you